Hello there!
Are you tired of using tokenizers for your
language transformers?
Highly likely you’re not, because usually,
these lines from the huggingface library do
the heavy lifting for you, so you usually
do not care about tokenization.
But tokenization, is a pre-processing step,
therefore it is rigid and not adapted to your
application nor your data.
But wait no more: Charformer is here, enabling
end-to-end language transformers, that do
not require tokenization anymore!
Ms. Coffee Bean, are we cool?
You know what happened in our last video and
I only wanted to know if we are ok now.
Yes?
Cool.
Tokenization is that part in pre-processing
that is done to text
before throwing it into your favourite language
model, say BERT.
It’s a pre-processing step, so it is independent
of the later training process, but it's crucial
for most transformers.
Without tokenization, each word of the English
vocabulary would have to be assigned a unique
vector on the input side
and, when predicting the masked word in the
output, the choice would have to consider
the whole vocabulary.
And if you believe that the English vocabulary
that one can find in a dictionary, is already
huge, think about how it can grow even faster
with all words that are not in a dictionary,
like compound words created on the fly by
someone as a stylistic figure.
Or all possible typos, right?
A mistyped word is also a word and should
have a way to be processed by a language model.
This is where tokenization comes in, to at
least partially, solve this problem by creating
a smaller vocabulary of word building blocks.
This hopes to cover as much of the dictionary
as possible, including unexpected words.
Therefore, tokenizers first segment the sentence
into words (harder for some languages than
for others, looking at you, Chinese, Thai
and Korean, because you do not have whitespace
separation).
Then the words are parsed into sub-words,
so that even though supposedly the dictionary
does not have the word “pre-processing”
in it, and therefore no vector representation
to associate with it, the tokenizer can divide
the word into “pre” and “processing”,
supposing that “pre” and “processing”
are already in the vocabulary and have a vector
association.
And this works great in very regular kinds
of words that can be decomposed into known
blocks, but does not solve the problem of
noisy text, full of typos where the possibilities
of mistyping are so many, that a fall-back
to a known subword is either impossible or
leads to misunderstandings.
So tokenization, being so rigid can become
a problem, an even bigger one when working
with multiple languages where the out-of-vocabulary
problem becomes even greater with every additional
language the model has to handle.
Even more, the downside of tokenization is
that on downstream applications, you are kind-of
forced to use the same tokenizer as the model
was trained with, because the trained model
is very much dependent on the tokenization
it is used to.
Even though your task might benefit from other
tokenizations, you now must stick with the
initial ones.
No, you're not allowed to see other tokenizers,
Ms. Coffee Bean!
Here is where Charformer comes to save the
day:
what if you would have a completely end-to-end
language transformer that does not require
this tokenization pre-processing step,
and takes in the text as-it-is: in characters
and dynamically computes fitting representations
for your task and data on the fly?
But Ms. Coffee Bean wants to know, why do
we need the Charformer in the first place?
What if we would take in the characters,
give them all an initial vector representation
and throw them like that into the transformer
and... boom?
Problem solved.
Well, Ms. Coffee Bean… it is not that easy.
On the one hand, it is exactly what related
work does.
But that also means that
the sequence length for the transformer would
be the same as the number of characters.
This can be a lot, which increases computation
and memory complexity.
Significantly.
Therefore the Charformer enables faster processing
of raw character inputs, by dynamically tokenizing
the characters into sub-words, then feeding
the tokenizations into a transformer and training
everything jointly, so tokenizer and transformer
at once.
Hereby it achieves the flexibility of other
character-level models, but does not blow
up the sequence length because it learns a
tokenizer which reduces the sequence length,
on the fly.
Tokenization with gradient shagabum, nice!
So great, now that we know what happens high-level,
let’s see under the hood.
Every time the authors say “character”,
they mean "byte", because this is how they
encode each character,
allowing them to work with many languages,
where all language characters are all encoded
in this byte space.
So the idea is to have your input, which is
a sequence of L characters, each encoded by
d-dimensional vectors, here 8-dimensional
bytes.
And the goal with this learned tokenization,
called Gradient-Based Subword Tokenization,
or short GBST
so GBST... is to find suitable representations
of spans of characters to then pass them on
together to the transformer.
Here in the visualization, a vector is denoted
just by x_1.
For this, GBST takes the character sequence
and their byte representation, and forms character
blocks, a little like n-grams.
So first are the 1-grams, there the block
size is 1, then we have the two-character
blocks, 3 character blocks and so on.
And GBST computes a representation for each
block
by mean pooling the representations of each
character in each block.
Ms. Coffee Bean, didn’t we say that we want
to reduce the sequence length?
Now we have 4 sequences instead of one and
by mean pooling we lost the order of the individual
characters for block sizes bigger than 1,
what are we even doing?
Aaah, the recipe goes further: In order to
avoid losing the order by mean pooling the
authors add: positional embeddings!!, which
are encoding the order of characters in the
blocks.
Okay, problem solved!
Are we going to reduce the length now?
Note that for bigger block sizes, we have
fewer vectors than the number of characters,
so the mean pooled representation of each
block is repeated now,
such that now every character has one vector
assigned to it.
So here x1 equals x2, because x2 is just copied
from x1.
For the 2-grams.
Or the 2-blocks.
Now the idea is to get a new, better representation
for each character.
One way to do it is by hard selection, by
choosing one representation from all the 4
possibilities
and to throw away the rest.
But the authors proposed soft selection,
by a weighted sum of all block representations.
The weights here, in other words the scorings,
are learned.
It is the only part in this tokenizer that
is learned through SGD on the task and its
data.
It kind-of makes sense that this part is learned,
unlike the other parts where mean pooling
is hard-coded, because for getting sensible
importance scores from the vectors, they first
have to be adapted to the data.
So we now have a new representation for each
character being the weighted sum of the block
representations.
So wait a minute: what has just happened here?
Well, in simple words, GBST basically asks:
what does each character need from its fellow
characters to inform its representation?
And what if each character can choose between
1-gram information, 2-gram, 3-gram and so
on?
Or even better: each character has the option
to do a combination of 1-gram, 2-gram ... information!
In order to determine how much they should
be combined, a transformation is learned to
determine these importances.
The gradient updates will tell the linear
transformation responsible for computing the
scores how much scoring is needed.
It is almost like attention, with the only
difference that each block position is uninformed
about what the other positions do and how
they combine things.
So now, (similarly to the MLP-Mixer or the
FNet which is the Fourier Transform Transformer),
we have first mixed the characters among each
other by neighbourhood,
then we mix again, but this time orthogonal
to the first mixing.
I honestly did not expect to find any parallel
between the MLP-Mixer and the Charformer,
but here it is.
And now we have as many representations as
characters, yay!
Well, not yay.
We started with L characters and their raw
representations, now we still have L character
representations, which are now more informed,
yes, but didn’t we say we want to reduce
sequence length?
Yes, we did, and this is the final step of
GBST:
downsampling.
These new L learnt character representations
are downsampled again by a mean-pooling operation
over neighbouring representations.
And this is hard-coded, not learned.
The only learnable step in GBST tokenizer
is the scoring of the character n-gram representations.
Wow.
So is this tokenization procedure elegant,
what do you think?
Well, we honestly, don’t know,
does it *have* to be elegant?
Mixing is all you need, the mixing does not
even have to be learned,
as we have seen in the Fourier Transform Transformer
and in other previous videos.
Any mixing and that’s what these authors
also do, often hard-coded, seems to work with
transformers.
So, was this long road of character representation
mixing worth it?
Yes, it kind-of was.
These new representations from the GBST tokenizer
are ready to be fed into your favourite transformers.
Especially because very little aspects in
GBST are learned, optimization will not waste
a lot of time on the tokenizer part.
Also, the tokenizer reduces the sequence length,
making the transformer downstream also faster.
I guess you can convince yourself of the performance
of the Charformer on the tables in the paper
(linked below).
Charformer is sometimes superior, sometimes
on-par with state-of the art character-level
models on GLUE.
Also, this approach works well in multilingual
settings and also on noisy text, where hard-coded
tokenization is brittle usually.
This good performance is somewhat expected,
because now the tokenization adapts to your
dataset and task while not blowing up your
sequence length.
And 0.1% state-of-the art up-and-down is less
important for Ms. Coffee Bean than the flexibility
of the Charformer on all the other applications
other than GLUE.
So yeah, I guess that this paper, even though
framed differently from the MLP-Mixer, the
transformer replacing self-attention with
convolutions or the Fourier Transform transformer,
is again showing that mixing representations
somehow, almost anyhow works, as long as you
have an transformer-like architecture in general
downstream.
And yes, by this we mean that self-attention
is not essential for transformers,
see this video linked below for more about
that.
Hmm… but this whole mixing, right? this
reminds us of something, Ms. Coffee Bean.
What was it?
Aaah, yes!
You know, those times of feature engineering
long gone?
Now I guess it’s time for mixing engineering.
Cheers to that!
Ms. Coffee Bean, what are you doing?
Ms. Coffee Bean?
Noo…!
I thought we were friend again!
No, Ms. Coffee Bean!?
Okay bye!